Don’t miss out.
>> I’M NOT ABLE TO SIT HERE AND
NOT COMMENT ON THIS IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS DONALD TRUMP’S
FAULT.
>> I DO NOT THINK THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTED LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEY THREW UP EVERY OBSTACLE
POSSIBLE TO PERMIT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> THESE KIDS ARE COMING HERE
MAKING THAT KIND OF JOURNEY AND
THEY AREN’T GOING TO BE ALLOWED
TO STAY IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> 90% OF THESE CHILDREN HAVE A
PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS HAVE NOT TAKEN
THE TIME TO COME TO THE BORDER
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT HAVE DIRECTED ME TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES AT THE
BORDER.
>> Gillian: THAT WAS REPUBLICAN
SENATORS TEARING INTO DHS
SECRETARY MAYORKAS AT A HEARING
OVER THE BORDER CRISIS.
HE HAS REPEATEDLY INSISTED THAT
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
ALL WEEK LONG OUR FOX NEWS
CAMERAS AND DRONES HAVE BEEN ON
THE SCENE CAPTURING A DIFFERENT
STORY WITH WAVES OF MIGRANTS
CROSSING THE RIO GRANDE RIVER
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT GETTING TO
THE OTHER SIDE LANDING THEM IN
THE UNITED STATES.
ONE PERSON WHO KNOWS THE
SITUATION FIRSTHAND WHO IS
THERE EVERY DAY, SHERIFF
MARTINEZ CONTROLS THAT SECTION
OF THE BORDER IN DEL RIO, TEXAS.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME WITH
US TODAY.
LET’S ASK THE POLITICAL
QUESTIONS FIRST HERE.
YOU HEARD THE SENATORS ARGUING
DOES IT MATTER WHOSE FAULT THE
CRISIS IS AT THIS POINT?
WE HAVE A VERY SERIOUS
SITUATION, IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT
PAPERWORK COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY, WRISTING THEIR LIVES
SOME GETTING SICK WHEN THEY
ARRIVE HER MAKING THE SITUATION
BAD FOR AMERICANS.
ISN’T IT TIME TO LOOK FOR A
SOLUTION RATHER THAN WHOSE
FAULT IT IS?
>> IT IS TIME TO LOOK FOR A
SOLUTION.
THIS PROBLEM HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR GENERATIONS.
ONE ADMINISTRATION PASSING THE
BLAME TO ANOTHER ADMINISTRATION.
IT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL THE LEGAL
PROCESS TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY
IF THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING
FOR.
>> Gillian: SO TELL US, YOU ARE
USED TO SEEING NOT VIDEOS OF
THESE SCENARIOS BUT SEEING THEM
HAPPEN IN FRONT OF YOUR EYES IN
REALTIME.
WHAT DO YOU SEE WHEN YOU SEE
THE MIGRANTS CROSSING THE RIVER
LIKE THAT?
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT STRIKES
YOU AS UNUSUAL, IS IT SOMETHING
THAT STRIKES YOU AS ORDINARY?
LOOKING AT THESE IMAGES RIGHT
NOW IT LOOKS INCREDIBLE TO
THOSE OF US WHO AREN’T USED TO
SEEING IT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
>> WELL, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS NOT TAKEN PLACE IN THIS
PART OF OUR COUNTY EVER.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE’VE
EXPERIENCED SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IT IS OVERBURDENED OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS, BORDER PATROL DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
IMMIGRANTS FLEEING THEIR HOME
COUNTRY LOOKING FOR A BETTER
WAY OF LIFE.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THERE HAS TO BE A SYSTEM
IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS THEM A
LEGAL PROCESS.
IT IS HEARTBREAKING THE WATCH
SOME OF THESE FAMILY UNITS
DRAGGING THEIR SMALL CHILDREN
ACROSS A RIVER RISKING THEIR
LIFE.
>> Gillian: IT IS.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
LOOKING AT THIS DAY AFTER DAY.
WE SEE EVEN SMALL CHILDREN AND
BABIES SOMETIMES ABANDONED ONCE
THEY GET TO THE U.S. SIDE OF
THE BORDER.
SO LOOKING AHEAD, SHERIFF,
BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCE, WHAT
CAN AND SHOULD BE DONE IN THE
NEAR TERM?
YOU AREN’T GOING TO SOLVE THIS
OVERNIGHT BUT AT LEAST TO
ALLEVIATE A LITTLE BIT OF THIS
CRISIS.
IS THERE ANYTHING?
>> SO I WISH THAT A DECISION
WILL BE MADE ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER AS TO TO STOP THIS.
MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DIE.
OUR STATE PARTNERS ARE INVOLVED
IN CAR CHASES EVERY DAY.
THERE ARE ACCIDENTS AND PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO DIE COMING HERE.
WE NEED TO PUT A STOP TO THIS
NONSENSE UNTIL WE COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION.
IT WILL ALWAYS GET WORSE.
PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE TO COME.
>> Gillian: QUICK LAST QUESTION
FOR YOU.
DO YOU SEE ANY REASON WHY THIS
MIGHT NATURALLY ABATE OVER THE
COMING MONTHS YES OR NO?
>> NO.
>> Gillian: NO, ALL RIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
AND SHARING YOUR INSIGHT.
WE APPRECIATE GETTING A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AT WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND, SHERIFF.